I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death and I fear no evil cuz I'm
blind to it all ammamma PlayStation
experience 2016 has just wrapped up and
the show ended with what I think is one
of the most exciting reveals that they
could have had which was the last of his
part to the last of us when it ended I
said that it didn't need another game
but after watching this trailer I really
want to play more but it left us with a
lot of questions as well yeah so this
showed le definitely you know much older
or immediately a few years at least
she's got a sleeve tattoo of her
knuckles are bloody which she find out
later trailer it's because she just
killed like six guys in this house
before he old strolls in with his life
plenty on her face like bloody knuckles
and everything and she playing guitar
and singing you know some biblical song
everything but yeah that kind of raises
questions as to did she believe Joel's
lie at the end of the last of us did she
just kind of accept it she mentions that
she's going to find and kill every last
one of them so they show the fireflies
logo early in the trailer on this sign
kind of graffiti Don wondering if she
has beef with the fireflies now more so
than she did before who else she could
be talking about her a new faction we
don't know about you know in general
just what happened since the last of us
because it was a pretty crazy ending so
like you I thought it ended well but now
that I've see these characters I'm
pretty hyped to see it more of it and
they can take it in a completely
different direction as well because
there were so few details in this like
there could be a whole other plot
running through this or maybe a whole
new enemy that's the taking the name or
the logo of the fireflies and maybe
changing them in a direction that they
don't want things to go but but at the
very least the who world still look
shitty yeah the trailer opened on these
overgrown cars like oh it's the last of
us jokingly especially because I think I
don't think we would have seen two
announcements from Naughty Dog at PSX
but here we find ourselves as it pans
out you're like no that looks a lot like
the last of us there's no way but then
of course you know she starts playing
the song it was a very you know like a
crew sick song there like like kind of
reminiscent of you know that
post-apocalyptic folk music that people
just trying to
on to leave this shitty world they find
themselves and but I'm really looking
forward to seeing what has happened
since the end of the first game I think
one of the biggest questions is with
uncharted dlc coming out with a crash
bandicoot game on the way which isn't
necessarily done directly by naughty dog
but that's a lot of projects for a
studio is this actually going to come
out next year or is this something we're
just gonna see a little bit of what are
you doing kiddo I would be extremely
surprised we saw this game in 2017 like
Shawn Laden on stage at PSX was saying
naughty Dog's clarifying it was almost
like a tech demo was them like updating
their engine saying this is what its
gonna look like here the characters you
know it's gonna be this duo again but
because they're so early in development
and like you just said they're working
on or at least just finished at least
the Lost Legacy uncharted standalone
story chapter I will at least say it's
gonna be early 2018 we'll see this but
hopefully we get a trailer next year
yeah so the last of us part 2 trailer
you can watch that right now on gamespot
com we're probably not going to see more
of it until e3 2017 but for even more
up-to-date news stay tuned to gamespot
com where we'll be digging that this
game as much as we can I'm gonna find
and I'm gonna kill every last one of
them
[Music]